good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I
Jeff Sachs director of the Earth
Institute at Columbia University and
extremely honored and delighted to be
welcoming Prime Minister Laurent the
boat of Haiti I and Prime Minister you
know how many friends you have in this
community how many friends at Columbia
University and in the broader community
and I'm glad that people are out in
force this was a hot ticket to have a
chance to see you
we're very honored by the Prime
Minister's visit and we've just had a
wonderful meeting beforehand with some
of the scientists at the earth Institute
to discuss ways that information
technology and new strategies in fields
as varied as infrastructure Public
Health Education agronomy can be
effectively deployed and for that I
think we're all very very excited what
struck me in the meeting Prime Minister
was how much love and affection there is
for your country in our team and broadly
we spend a tremendous amount of time
thinking about worrying about and
helping Haiti and trying to be with you
in in the many challenges well we know
that Prime Minister Lamont is a very
dynamic leader of Haiti and he has been
throughout his life the youngest and
everything it seems youngest in
educational attainment a tennis star I
understand if I have that information
correct Davis Cup competitor and
youngest prime minister and
a very very very dynamic individual I do
think it's true was I go on in life I
find the Prime Minister's do get younger
and younger over time and that is good
lots of energy lots of new direction
lots of idealism and lots of capacity
Prime Minister LaMotte has a very
successful career in business in Haiti
and he's an entrepreneur and he brings
an entrepreneurial talent to this
mission and as we know that's what Haiti
needs now it needs the Entrepreneurship
of new directions of taking on the
challenges of building a new Haiti and
were eager to hear your ideas about that
and you know Prime Minister that we are
absolutely eager to help you in any way
and to partner along the way so without
further ado ladies and gentlemen please
join me in welcoming Prime Minister
laurent lamode who will speak today on
balancing foreign direct investment
disaster risks and development in Haiti
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much professor
Sachs
and thank you to all students and member
of the Haitian consulate ambassadors
member of the Haitian press and bear of
gph ro that are here thank you very much
for coming I'm delighted to be here with
you this afternoon as a speaker at this
university's prestigious world leaders
forum I am truly humbled to be following
the vast range of distinguished leaders
from around the world that have spoken
here on this very podium I'm also very
pleased that the urgency to directed by
Professor Sachs and Stephen Cohen is a
co-sponsor of this afternoon's event our
government has been very impressed with
your initiative in Haiti and the pilot
program you've launched in Peru Pema
we're particularly impressed and
interested with the results of the
baseline assessments of the river basins
in our southern peninsula and how these
will help us develop an integrated
watershed management program as the
first leader of Haiti to share this
stage and with such impressive audience
of scholars students businesspeople
journalists and others I feel especially
honored this afternoon I'll address an
issue of significant concern to my
country and the international community
how to balance foreign direct investment
disaster risk and the challenges of
development I might be the first Haitian
leader to address this forum many greet
Hitchens have been here before
recently in 2010 Michele Montes
an award-winning journalist who has
dedicated her life to securing
democratic values and freedom of our
country received the jeans medal for
public service from Columbia University
Jacque woman arguably his greatest poet
novelist journalist and acknowledges
also attended this great university in
the 1940s women raised vivid questions
in the 1930s and 40s that were and still
are very much relevant about some of the
issues facing our country today I'm
inspired by montage and by women's
ideals for a better more just and
democratic Haiti I must also say that
I'm very happy about the turnout this
afternoon because it demonstrates to me
the interest that you all have for the
development of my country and the deep
concern that you share for Haiti your
presence here this afternoon tells us
that you are with us and we appreciate
that thank you for coming
this afternoon I am facing an audience
of experts on a range of issues who have
not only produced extraordinary
scholarships but I've also been a part
of the policy discussions around these
topics in preparation for this
afternoon's talk
I again consulted for Jeffrey Sachs
who's thinking about how to move nations
out of situation of profound economic
crisis in poverty and how this has
influenced so many of us I want to begin
my remarks
by focusing on the development debate as
EDA has affected Haiti most of you are
familiar with the long litany of
generally negative descriptors that
appear in major academic works and that
prevail in journalistic accounts about
Haiti I will not repeat them this
afternoon but it is true that negative
descriptions are recurrent and more so
since the earthquake let me share with
you that over the course of the past
three years we have begun to gradually
prepare the way to revert these negative
traits to do our best to revert the
negative comments in my briefing -
afternoon I would like to examine where
we came from where we currently stand
and where we intend to reach within the
next few decades because the goal is to
make Haiti an emerging nation in 2030
Hades pattern of development has been
deeply influenced by three
characteristics one our original
development model was not significantly
different than the rest of the Western
Hemisphere export-led growth tide
generally - the agricultural sector and
with the weak or non-existent
of high value-added exports II unlike
the rest of the region Haiti has never
experienced an import substitution
strategy so our private sector has
remained small and traditional than
traditional generating few jobs and
relatively insignificant levels of
investment the state did not generate
sufficient revenues to fund any public
policy initiatives
not to mention basic social programs the
state was and continues to be the
largest employer especially of middle
sectors who are dependent on the largest
of the state to survive the state
currently hires 65,000 public sector
employees and many thousand others of
small jobs this development model
contributed to the centralization of
nearly everything in the capital city
port-au-prince which in turn accelerated
rural urban migration resulting in an
overcrowded capital city the city of
port-au-prince was built for 300,000
inhabitants it currently has three
million in this context the state and
the private sector have been incapable
of generating employment for the vast
majority of urban dwellers Haiti
presents an extreme version of a general
regional pattern that includes the
expansion of shanty towns where basic
services are scarce or non-existent and
where the vast majority of the
economically active population survives
in the informal economy the consequences
of this development model rendered Haiti
vulnerable to natural catastrophes that
that have only prolonged the state of
affairs in our country
the second dimension of Hades
development pattern is linked to a
recurrent pattern of foreign assistance
international aid has long been an
important source of income for Haiti but
the pattern of dependence deepened since
our country's transition to democracy in
the 1980s this is in fact a point that
Professor Sachs has long argued so I'm
not saying anything new or unfamiliar to
any of you today in the past 20 years
foreign assistance has become a largest
the large proportion of our state
revenue foreign assistance aimed largely
at helping us overcome natural events
and political instability inadvertently
also contributed to weakness or state
capacity as most of this assistance
bypassed specific government and relied
mainly on NGOs thus the state remained
the state revenue remain poor and
experienced an erosion of basic
functions it is also important not to
miss understand my position
Haiti is extremely grateful to the
international community for assisting us
especially in the great times of need my
point is simply that the pattern of
assistance has also contributed to the
weakness of our state the third
characteristic has been our profound
vulnerability to natural events such as
hurricanes floods droughts and most
recently the devastating earthquake in
2010 we sit in the middle of the
Caribbean and we are located in close or
into every single hurricane that passes
to the region we are somewhat affected
whether the eye goes over Haiti or not
thus
to govern Haiti it is important to
realize that each year we must be alert
to the possibility of a natural disaster
it means that we need strong
institutions and strong and strong into
institutional framework given the
profound weakness of the state the
capacity to respond to these events on
our own is very limited thus foreign
assistance is a reality that we have to
deal with in the aftermath of every one
of these events broadly defined this was
a state of affairs that our government
encountered when we have some office in
May of 2011 as this continue to be
profound structural changes that our
government faces for this very reason we
see our basic challenge today as
establishing a very very careful balance
between overcoming the legacies of the
pattern of development mitigating the
impact of natural events and making
Haiti a place that welcomes foreign
direct investments overcoming these
structural realities is not something
that can be accomplished overnight
it requires rigorously applied long term
development strategy over the course of
our 23 months in office we have been
guided by the parameters of our master
plan which is called a strategic plan
for the development of AD that has
established firm goals for a country for
the year 2030 under the terms of the
strategic plan we are focusing on four
major pillars of action that include
territorial rebuilding economic
rebuilding social rebuilding and
institutional rebuilding each of those
areas has developed specific programs
aimed at addressing
specific development challenges as for
the territorial rebuilding it calls for
programs and projects linked with
regional and urban planning Community
Development Environmental Protection
watershed rehabilitation urban renewal
national transportation systems
nationwide electricity distribution
expansion of telecommunication systems
and the creation of a national digital
network we also aim to improve the
drinking water supply and sanitation
capacities including solid waste
management in the area of economic
rebuilding we are focusing on the
implementation of coherent macroeconomic
policy support to private sector
investment modernization and
revitalization of our agriculture
livestock and fish reproduction
upgrading the competitive sectors of the
Haitian economy such as manufacturing
and tourism developing a construction
industry developing the service sector
ensuring the sustainable exploitation of
Jeolla geologic resources and
implementing employment generating
projects social rebuilding is perhaps
our most serious challenge to date it
includes the development of a network of
health care and educational facilities
throughout Haiti including higher
education and professional and
vocational training we are also pursuing
programs in that heritage protection and
arts support measures better access to
housing the development of civic action
sports recreation opportunities for all
in the institutional rebuilding it
includes revising the legal framework
reinforcing the administrative
structures of the legislative and
judicial branches modernizing the civil
service
including the police public security and
others
increasing the number of regional civil
service employees and reinforcing local
government and administration's and
administration's and civil society this
is the framework that underlines our
policy efforts and that helps us through
this precarious balance between our
development legacies of vulnerability to
inertia to natural events and our
recurrent need for the right type of
foreign assistance namely foreign direct
investment what have we done so far I
would like to share with you some of the
efforts that we've conducted under the
theme of the long term strategic
development plan we are convinced that
what we are doing today in Haiti is
setting the stage for the kind of
country that all of us here in this room
one Haiti to be by the year 2030 direct
foreign investment is the strategic
platform for a significant improving for
significantly improving Hades business
environment and creating the long term
jobs our people so desperately need the
success of our efforts to attract
foreign direct investments meaning that
Haiti is really open for business can be
seen in the successful projects now
underway those include a 617 acre 257
million industrial park in Caracol
recently completed this project
underwritten with funds from the IDE the
US government and and others is and is
an excellent example of what can be
achieved through
ships between the public sector and
interests and institution international
institutions Caracol is aligned with our
strategy plans for decentralization at
the same time is creating jobs over
1,500 jobs have been created so far our
government has committed to creating up
to 20,000 jobs in the northern area and
the anchor tenant saya has committed to
creating several thousand of those jobs
and saya is a major South Korean textile
manufacturer that's operating in Caracol
the second Industrial Park is expected
to create over 500 jobs in northern
port-au-prince and is a 58 million
dollar project with over 3,000 social
housing clinics sports centres water
treatment plant and a place where some
of the victims of the earthquake will be
able to find a decent place to live one
of the key growth areas is our tourism
development you know I'm very happy and
excited to see so much happening in the
tourism sector in such a short time over
the past 12 months the government has
approved 11 new hotel projects totaling
over 160 million dollars by adding the
rooms needed these projects give us the
receptive areas to be a top tourist
destination as importantly these new
hotels will create 1,600 new jobs and
6,500 indirect jobs in the most recent
report from the Str global release Haley
is rates as the fastest growing room
supply destination with plus 58.2%
growth in terms of rooms availability in
the country we are we have seen in the
past three months the opening of two new
hotels a five-star hotel first hotel
owned by an international chain
occidentalis also a Best Western Premier
which is the first American chain in
Haiti and according to the CEO the
nicest Best Western certainly in the air
in the hemisphere so we're very happy
about that
we have several hotels opening and the
country is taking off you feel that the
development of AD is finally happening
the nation-building that we're all been
waiting for is starting to happen we're
paving 735 kilometers of roads to give
better access and better communication
to cities we're building five new
airports we are investing in sports
infrastructure 15 new stadiums have been
built 50 small stadiums are being built
when this government arrived we had over
1.5 million half of the population was
homeless was living in tents from the
first day of of the administration
mandate till today we working non-stop
to move these people that are our
brothers and sisters from living in
subhuman conditions under tents into
their original neighborhoods with a year
worth of rental subsidy and so far we've
been able to move 80% of the tent
population since Columbia University is
one of the largest universities and the
most respected in the world
it's appropriate for me to note our
commitment to fundamentally transform
Hades educational system so that our
country is able to rely on a workforce
that make Haiti a competitive one we
have begun at the very bottom of the
system addressing the basic problems of
access to education when we took office
nearly half a million children had no
access to education taking into account
that the law in Haiti mandates free
schooling we have designed a specific
program to facilitate access to free
basic education to over 1.2 million
children that previously had to pay for
that schooling in a system where 80% of
the school system is private it is a
responsibility for the government of
ready to provide that and we are doing
our very best to do so we are putting
together a database an online database
to facilitate the management and
monitoring of the program have recruited
4853 new teachers to teach in more than
10,000 schools that are part of the
program we are building 200 new schools
and in order to continue funding we have
with doing significant financial reforms
in the education sector we have put in
surcharges to finance existing needs of
tuition for those the poorest children
and we're putting together reforms that
are that have been voted at the lower
chamber of Parliament for a national
education fund that will give Haiti the
first of its kind fund to be able to
finance the expansion of the education
system one of the stark realities that
we're facing in Haiti is the
vulnerability of people living in
extreme poverty
our goal is to lift as many people as
possible out of poverty and to set the
social safety net that will guarantee
acceptable living standards for most
Haitians we have put together the first
of its kind national assistance social
program it ranges from cash transfers to
the elderly and the disabled to hot
meals and subsidies for university
students and farmers this is the largest
and most structured social assistance
program ever to be implemented in the
country already millions of dollars have
been directed to the program with a
million people benefiting today our goal
is to assist over 5 million people by
the end of 2012 under this program
regular cash transfers to a first group
of 25,000 handicapped and 25,000 elderly
Haitians in need
we are also assisting 100,000 destitute
mothers leave those living in extreme
poverty already 57,000 have reefs have
received their benefits over 22,000
University students are receiving
subsidies and 60,000 farming kids have
been given out to farmers to work their
land this is the first time in its
history that Haiti has attempted such a
vast and orderly social initiative we
have allocated 0.4% of our GDP per
capita to this program with 50 million
dollars already spent the government is
looking at expanding this program
because we have the commitment we are
committed to the goal of lifting as many
Haitians as possible because we feel
that living in extreme poverty
in 2013 is simply unacceptable and we
will do the best we can to help
our brothers and sisters living in that
inhumane situation to conclude allow me
to thank each and every one of you and
to tell you a little bit about a recent
surprise visit that I had in one of
mother Prince's poorest neighborhoods I
went at 11:30 at night and a young
mother told me that she never learned
how to read nor write and neither did
her mom neither did her grandparents and
her kids were going to face the same
faith with tears in your eyes she told
me that thanks to the free schooling
program her child her four children will
be better than she ever was because the
children are learning the basic reading
and writing segments like this and
gestures like this are a very small step
into understanding the depth of helping
millions of people that have never been
held before people that have never
received any assistance from any
governments before people that had to
fight to drink a glass of water glass of
potable water this is our commitment and
these are the real stories of the Haiti
that we are attempting to build one that
cares one that is solely there that has
solidarity towards the weakest one that
wants to fight to get rid of corruption
one that wants to do better one that
wants to have a better image that wants
to be seen around the world as making
the best possible effort to get out of
the cycle of poverty and one that every
Haitian
can be proud of thank you very much
professor Sachs for having me thank you
Paul it's a pleasure to be here
well thank you very much mr. prime
minister
my name is Glendenning director of the
Center on globalization and sustainable
development at the earth Institute and
his Excellency the Prime Minister has
kindly agreed to take some questions
from the audience
he'd especially like to hear from some
of the students here today but everybody
is welcome I I would ask you to please
keep your questions very brief to the
point we would not like to hear speeches
but we'd like to hear from you and hear
from as many of you as possible
would you please begin with your name
and your affiliation so I think we
possibly have our first speaker yeah
yes could you come to the microphone
please
hello everyone my name is drew can fit
not I'm Haitian and also I'm a proud
alum of Columbia University it's great
to be back and it's great to see a prime
minister so my question is I am
currently also doing projects in Haiti
and I can attest to what you just said
in terms of the changes that huh that
are happening on the ground but the
question I'd like to ask you
particularly is what plan what are the
plans in place to guarantee or to make
sure that those social programs that you
mentioned are we mean after the terms of
the presidency so what are the framework
to guarantee that those program will be
there like you know after you leave
office that's a very good question one
that I get asked very often the people
want to see that these are sustainable
programs because they help so many so
many people so one of the right now we
have started because we needed to start
because of the extreme emergency and we
are reviewing a set of strategies to
introduce a fund and introduce new taxes
in order to carry this forward
permanently to have a permanent tax
system in order to fund some of these
programs and reallocate some other taxes
that are going to programs into these
programs that actually work because some
of the other social programs you know
they touch very few people for example
the Casa systems who shall be stretching
less than 10,000 people we want to touch
as many people as possible we already we
already reaching about a million and we
feel that with the introduction of some
permanent fiscal additions we'll be able
to maintain some of those programs for
the long run please line up at the
microphone Prime Minister thank you for
for being here my name is Jacob christum
in the journalism program here and I
have a question about a major source of
foreign direct investment for many
developing countries is mining
obviously there are a number of North
American mining companies very large
ones including Newmont and Eurasian
exploring for minerals right now in
Haiti and I understand that the head of
the longtime head of the Bureau the of
mining and energy was kind of forced out
recently in favor of somebody else I
guess my question is what is Haiti's
guard what legislation is currently
under consideration being in legislation
or conventions to ensure that an
eventual mine that's opened in Haiti
benefits the government and the rural
population as there is as best as
possible thank you very much for your
question and we're doing two things one
we are reviewing the mining law to make
sure that they not only protect the
haitian knowing that it protects Haiti
itself but that it also protects the
environment of the local population
that's what - we're doing an assessment
of the natural resources that we have to
determine their worth because one of the
initial point that we must do before we
start even you know engaging is is to
know what is the words of what we have
with the evaluation once we have those
two will be better equipped with
certainly assistance from experts to
negotiate the best possible agreements
along with the Parliament of Haiti you
know to have the best possible agreement
where Haitian where Haiti will benefit
as you see we don't have that many
resources so the few ones that we have
we want to make sure that they are
utilized that they're maximized to the
fullest hi my name is Madhu Saraswati
and I'm a graduate student here at
Columbia University and my question is
relating to your comments on the need
for Haiti to prepare for future natural
disasters I was wondering if you could
speak a little bit about how Haiti is
integrating climate change into those
preparedness efforts what we're doing
right now is many things first we are
organizing ourselves with a permanent
risk this
Astra management office because up till
now they were it has it hadn't been
clearly defined so we're investing in
that second we're working on system of
alerts to alert the population in case
of for example an earthquake or in
better communication systems 3 in terms
of prevention we are working to equip
for example we build 10 hurricane
shelters which never existed before so
the problem is every time you had a
flooding every time you had a natural
disaster well the people the most
vulnerable people went into shelters
that happened to be schools so when the
disaster would last a long time the
people don't want to leave their school
so now you have a problem with the
disaster when people moved out of where
they're supposed to be and they go into
schools were blocked in several school
from the school system so we've built
some hurricane disaster shelters we also
for the children in the you know for the
orphans because there is many from the
earthquake and they are very vulnerable
because they're on the street we build
also 9 transit centers you know where we
could move where we're moving them to
that they have a place to go and general
the policy we're structuring the the
risk management system you know we we're
all government ministries are touched
and are sensitized towards the problem
of preparedness something that hadn't
been done in the past we would prepare
just a few days before and now the whole
government machinery is being oiled and
it's being geared towards you know
disaster prevention and risk management
so on top of all that we are working to
to reinforce some of the insurance
system that we have because after every
natural disaster there is great losses
and the insurance you usually do not
cover for that type of hurricane damage
and natural and natural disasters so we
are working in order to get to that
point so that it doesn't D capitalize
people every time there is a problem so
we are touching several different
until we get it right mr. prime minister
thank you very much for speaking with us
today
my name is Gerald McElroy I work with an
education NGO in the Dominican Republic
that works with Haitians and I'm also a
student in the Masters of development
practice program with Professor Denney
and professor wah my question for you
today is you taught you stressed the
importance of international involvement
in development in Haiti in future years
this isn't a country that has
historically had the involvement of
short-sighted foreigners and NGOs and
other organizations what is your what
steps is your administration taking to
ensure that the involvement of the
international community is productively
contributing to Hades development and
also what role do you see the Diaspora
playing in the coming years I'm you have
a very vibrant Haitian diaspora in
Canada the United States Europe how do
you envision their involvement one for
the NGO there is two things one we are
restructuring the oversight and
monitoring of the NGOs to know where
they are what they are doing and whether
what they're doing falls within the
Hades master plan which is the strategic
development plan of Haiti so long as it
does also what we asked of the NGO is
that they don't I mean right now the
sort of somewhat compete with the
Haitian government for funding that
normally would go to nation-building and
nation-building is the work of the
government with with experts what we
envision the role of the NGOs to be is
to be there to support us to compliment
us not to compete with the government
that's very important distinction so in
order not to compete we're putting
together this plan that that would be
that will define clearly their work
scope of the NGOs you know on websites
and to see exactly what NGOs are doing
in what area we don't want the NGOs to
go completely but we don't want them to
compete with the government in terms of
nation-building and reconstruction the
the the diaspora has a prominent role to
play because if you want to rebuild a
society if you want to rebuild a country
85% of our we have a brain drain factor
you know 85% of
his brains has has left to come to the
United States or or friends or kind of
there are others so in order to rebuild
a country
the type of rebuilding that we want to
see happen
we definitely need every brain that's in
the jaspera to be able to go back now we
have different issues a lot of the
brains they are working here on very
high salaries so they won't necessarily
want to go back for it for I mean for
lower pay so in order to compensate that
we're working on a program that will
compensate the P that they're losing in
order for them to benefit and there is
several of them already you know going
back but the challenge is to get
everybody that wants to get back at
equal pay and equal benefits so that's a
challenge because you know we're asking
them to sacrifice to come back to the
country and to help but then we have to
we also have to provide some basic
necessities for them to come back and
sometimes it's very challenging because
as we have our own challenges in Haiti
in the public administration sector to
give you a simple example a minister in
the government and $2,000 $24,000 a year
so if I tell for example a professor of
Columbia's for Asian American to come in
or a doctor that's you to come and move
back to Haiti we need to find a way to
compensate some of the salaries because
I doubt that they will come for the 24 K
years mr. prime minister thank you very
much for being here my name is Natasha
Castelli and I am Haitian good
fortunately you've actually touched up a
question that I had because what I
really wanted to know is for those of us
who are part of the Diaspora and who are
willing ready and capable of
participating in the changes that your
government is currently making what what
is next
well one thing that new president says
and and it's you know Haiti is a free is
a free is an entrepreneurial type of
society people can open whatever
business that you want to succeed so a
lot of it I mean I mean we need to find
a way to compensate for some of the risk
but then we need three stickers as well
because at the end of the day anybody
can open a business in Haiti and anybody
can open schools anybody can open a car
dealership anybody can open a restaurant
anybody can open whatever that they
would want now
the Haitian Americans living here have
an added advantage that they have some
capital whereas the Haitian doesn't have
access to capital so you will be in a
much better position to open a business
you know to go to Haiti work on the
economic recovery but then then there
needs to be some type of risk-taking
that has to happen on both ends the
government alone won't be able to
accommodate for four million people
living in the Jasper we can do a program
where we accommodate some but then what
we need to do and what we've been doing
is creating the basic security situation
right now the security has greatly
improved in Haiti and continues to
improve actually in terms of statistic
according to the UNODC
Office he is as safe as Long Beach
California
because we have eight crimes for every
hundred thousand people same as Long
Beach so Long Beach has better marketing
than we do and we working on that but
the the idea is that statistics never
line members net members don't lie now
the idea for the Haitian Americans is to
take the risk as well you need to take
some some risk and the reward is greater
because you have up to now very little
competition the market is open so if you
have a good idea you know if you want to
open a restaurant instead of going to
open it in
you know in New York coming that come on
down to open and in Haiti you have you
have a better market and you'll have
less competition so those are ideas that
it doesn't have to and I don't want
everybody to think that the government
itself the government has very little
reach in terms of opening of businesses
what we can do which we've done is to
make it easier for you to open a
business and today you can go online on
CFI website CFI is the investment office
and you can open a company of the buyer
company of the shelf for half the price
you would cost to open a company in
Haiti so this is what we can do but then
again like I've been saying like John F
Kennedy said don't ask what your country
can do for you
ask for what you can do for your country
because that's why we need the 85
percent of the of the Haitians living
abroad we need you to ask right now what
can you do for Haiti and come and help
us thank you
my name is Frederick I'm affiliated with
at the mailman School of Public Health
uptown my question is about the recent
outbreak of cholera in your country what
is the government plan to address this
outbreak and is the government prepared
to lead even in the event that the
nation states of the United Nation do
not fully fund the recovery efforts
thank you we've done a long way to solve
that the cholera issue the Ministry of
Health has put put out the national
health plan to deal with cholera along
with our systems with the CDC to have a
vaccine and right now the cholera cases
have gone way down I mean I we're
talking about less than three cases per
day up from you know over five six
thousand so right now it's closely it's
close to disappearing and we have two
studies one from the CDC that data that
preaches I mean that specifies the use
of vaccines and then we have another
study by a French professor that states
we that with very little funding in the
dry season we can you know get rid of
the disease completely but Haiti is is
not the cholera right now is his own is
disappearing good afternoon mr. prime
minister my name is Walter jean-jacques
I'm also Haitian myself I'm the
co-president the Haitian two Association
and I'm also the nephew of Senator Ardis
we share the vice president the Haitian
Senate and my question pertains to the
kita not go move me I want to ask your
opinion of how does that influence the
particular unification of Haiti
currently well before I answer the
questions and I'm at Columbia I'm gonna
ask if anybody knows what key Donohue is
if not that's a Google send you to
Google search it's a movement that that
are initiated in in the department where
sanitary she is in the goddess in Leslie
WA and it's a solidarity movement where
they have a trunk of tree that they cut
and
truck of tree is traveled all across
Haiti in all the different cities and is
pushed by different groups of people
from town to town to town to town
until it reached the end point which is
on the other side of Haiti so it travels
several hundred kilometers and and as a
solidarity movement so the people they
really don't sleep there 24 hours a day
you know carrying the I mean handing and
in handing off the trunk of tree until
it gets to the destination so it was it
was a way for the organizers to show
unity and solidarity among Haitians
because Haiti historically has been a
very divided country has been a country
because you have a lot of inequalities
in the country the society has been
bitterly divided and that movement was a
movement to show that we strength unity
and solidarity we can do great things so
I give you the best possible explanation
that I could and I invite you to Google
the rest for additional information but
it was a very important and significant
movement for him we have our last two
questions thank you thanks for coming my
name is Gregory Paul I'm a senior at
Columbia College majoring economics and
being Haitian American it's very
welcoming being here this is a two-part
question I just want to know what
specific steps are you taking to kind of
spread all this wealth of information
down to the people living in
port-au-prince and the people living
around the city I think one thing I
appreciate about Haiti is the model at
loon and fellow force is people coming
together and working together so what
steps is the administration taking to
kind of have this all this wealth of
information trickle down to the common
folk also there's not too much related
but what's stronger your forehand or
your backhand
back hill you know I see a bunch of
asian-americans graduating from Columbia
so maybe that's a good opportunity to
have an exchange program with Haiti
because all of you that graduate you
know we need you and your expertise and
what you learn here and I said the same
thing at Harvard where I had the speech
and MIT where we had we sign an exchange
program with MIT to assist with some of
the Human Resources challenges that we
have so since so many asian-americans
are here this is a good opportunity for
you too to help your country we are the
people in the in the people in the in
the townships they know the work that
we're doing because most of the work we
do it they're in cities Soleil which is
like the largest township in the country
you know we put for the first time ever
solar solar lamps all over all over the
town we invested I mean there is over
over 20,000 people that benefit from
some of the social assistance program we
have over 44 schools in those name in in
that particular neighborhood that that
is that offers free schooling the free
schooling program we have we have water
sanitation projects we're doing two new
stadiums so a lot of the projects that
we're doing they are being done inside
the poorest areas so they they are aware
of that and we have of course the radio
and community and we have a group that
talks to the different communities to
explain to them what we're doing so a
lot of work is being put into also
reaching out to the community and
telling them what we're doing for them
but they feel it also hello Thank You
mr. prime minister for being here my
name is Casey Hamilton and I'm a
freelance travel writer
I'm also Jamaican and I wondered what
are the long term
for developing tourism in Haiti if you
could explode on that you mentioned the
new hotels that open but I just wondered
what the long-term goal was for there is
four points one is the development of
hotels in the capital to have a good
reception capacity and that one we well
under we we have we have a brand new
five-star hotel that open we have
Darrell we have the best Western and the
existing hotels are expanding capacities
so - and then we have three major
tourist areas that we are pushing one is
is the southern peninsula the southern
coast where we are certain it's one of
the nicest beaches in Haiti and then we
have Jacmel which is a historic city
that's where patron helped Simon Bolivar
before he went to liberate South America
so we're investing in tourist
infrastructure is there forty million
dollars are going into new hotel giving
the roads fixing the drainage system
with management plans and we're doing a
lot to also bring up the cultural
heritage of this wonderful and historic
city of Jacmel and we're doing something
out of the box which is investing in for
the first time in offshore island which
is again that's your homework after I'm
done here which is investing in a la
Hache the lavash is by far and when you
do the research you you will see what
I'm saying by far the nicest island in
the Caribbean it has I mean nothing
against Jamaica
but we are pushing that with a 40
million dollar government investment and
also there is private investment that
are going to come there we're building
an airport on a lavash to have a
independent tourist destination so that
when you want to come here you know you
think you fly Delta and you land strain
on innovation and you have a paradise
you know around you with nice white
sandy beaches Sunday year-round and warm
people best foods so we want to give you
that Haitian experience for you all to
to see for yourself so we I mean we are
pushing significantly the investment
there and this will be a one-of-a-kind
island for you all to enjoy thank you
so thank you Thank You Prime Minister
I take away a couple of big messages
from from the talk this afternoon and
the first one is for our vacations we
have to go to Haiti and not Long Beach
or anywhere else for that matter
second if you're a real entrepreneur
like the Prime Minister you'll invest in
Haiti and not in New York City I think I
got that right I can't speak on behalf
of the University but I do think that
we're very open to exploring the kind of
exchange discussions that you've had
with Harvard and MIT and we'll see if we
can we can match those with the kind of
enthusiasm that you saw from the
students this afternoon we're really
grateful for the time that you've spent
with us at the world leaders forum we
thank you for sharing the 2030 vision
the current programs and the progress
that you're very clearly making we're
also grateful for your very candid and
insightful responses to the various
questions from the audience and I think
on behalf of the whole group we wish you
a successful continuation of your
mission in the United States so ladies
and gentlemen please thank the Prime
Minister for coming here with us today